[Music]
[Applause]
hey here we are folks we might be drunk
we're here we're back what are you
cooking up there fatty well you know
what I I was making hot totties over the
weekend on my gig and uh they're kind of
nice aren't they yeah you got the
thermos and everything this is real this
is our producer Matt Peters who and this
isn't water this is his tears from the
Buffalo Bills last night oh [__] I'm
sorry buddy we'll get them next year
that was a tough loss I was rooting for
you guys man I know I I thought you had
it and you you had all the Jews clear
out the snow they dug it out and you
still lost why strikes again weren't
they weren't they sacrificing a person
to that pit every week oh that was funny
yeah you have a pit they have like a 20
foot pit and someone fell in what pull
it up they're digging a new stadium are
you on Mike yeah okay good yeah yeah
they're doing a new stadium so there was
a pit and someone fell in and they won
what like six straight games really yeah
he went to the hospital someone's going
to the hospital they're like sacrif iing
him hey good Luck's good luck Sports and
religion have more in common than you
think meet on Sunday yeah Die Hard
uniform
uniform uh hit your wife women get
[__] that's something some some men in
a naked naked males yeah that's
something there a lot of fighting the
opposing thought right they on the other
team you say Jason Kelce before the game
yeah that guy's I mean you can't not
love that guy pulled a full Bert Ker
yeah he looked like he looked like bird
which I think a compliment to bird at
this point that's true yeah that's true
but Jason Kelce is like do you know how
likable you have to be to have like
everyone in football like you yeah I
mean it's like look at that I mean look
at this dude you gotta love this is why
Twitter I know everybody shits on X but
it during a sports game there's nothing
better the whole country is coming
together making memes making jokes
putting videos together it's great I
don't get half of it and I watch your
Stu stuff and you're blowing up with the
with the sports tweets H just you just
got to be timely yeah but uh great but
man uh it's pretty fun it's uh
football's great it's just [__] it's
fun the playoffs in any sport just get
me going but uh oh back to the religion
thing the only difference is you can't
switch teams like you can't be a fair
weather you can people do switch really
I guess you can have no respect right
right you know you're like ah the
Muslims are losing this year I'm going
Christian Jews are having a bad year
you're like going
Islam yeah there's something there Fair
control the weather fan alluka honey for
it too buddy Manuka I got this at
customs in Australia really yeah they
off duty or whatever ohe off duty what
the hell is wrong with me what is
dutyfree I walk through it I never oh
and you could bring it on although they
[__] you if you want to if you're
connecting they [__] you you have to
that's an issue you have to pay the tax
no you liquid ah those bastards we
something all right is this all it is is
water honey and booze yeah oh I didn't
know that yeah buddy I thought some
people do it with the tea bags that's
kind of weird to me and it hurts the
nuts it's amazing that whiskey used to
be like a medicine like he used to go
buy boo still is man I got postnasal
drip right now this time of year I feel
like dog [__] always you H I'm okay I'm
I'm an ox but it's funny like when you
were a baby my mouse you're
fival back in the day they put you know
a kid out of tooth thck they put a
whiskey on it yeah it's a bad doctor
yeah yeah or or a good
friend yeah this is good stuff
cheers and some with the mug you feel
like you're a you know a lady on after
divorce he hit
me well the Bills lost oh can I run a b
i IDE by you oh we're going right in huh
I was thinking about this you never hear
like sometimes when a woman is accused
of sexual assault especially not a I
mean she accuses a man of sexual assault
right a woman accuses a man of sexual
assault and it's high-profile people
will comment on her appearance like he
is he raped her ah and it's like that
how [__] up is that that this person
might have been sexually assaulted and
now they're calling her ugly too right
and by the way you never hear it the
other way it's never like oh he raped
her a nice selection oh I like that
never hear that right I like it I don't
know that's good maybe something there
it's so true all right I got one now
okay we were just in Ohio doing it doing
some shooting and every neighborhood I
go to now all over the country though
like five years ago this was all gang
shooting crime you couldn't come in here
then the gays came in now it's
gentrified and I'm like the gays are
just quietly fixing up all these shitty
neighborhoods and not getting any credit
we should be parachuting them into
Detroit and uh Like Flint and lower La
the Bronx you know then I got a couple
tags like forget Maga how about fagga
all right okay what about queer ey for
the south side of Chicago that's funny I
like that yeah that's good it's coming
along yeah man that's from that's all
from
Columbus Columbus is yeah that's good
all of Ohio is you know I mean dayon is
I think gotten a little rough right
Dayton and Toledo are tough yeah tough
towns but Cleveland's trying and
Columbus
the size of Cleveland and Cincinnati
combined really yeah yeah it's a bigger
city for sure Capital great town thanks
for coming I always have a good time in
Cleveland though I like Cleveland I do
too good Chinese food good Jewish deli
sliming oh yeah oh we ate so much meat
on this trip what were you eating the
corn beef and all that stuff called
schlitzes
Oris or it was just straight schmits
straight sausages German food brought
worst all that stuff
schnitzel heav Duty so good kills a
hangover get a big beer too one of those
we got the mug we got the what do you
call it Growler boot boot there you go I
got a boot on my car I got I had some
other bit I want to run by let me see
cuz I feel bad I repeated one last week
and it got me [__] oh
yeah all right oh is there something I
believe a woman's body is her choice but
you ever date someone and they get a new
haircut without consulting
you does feel kind of rude right like
it's like terminating a pregnancy is one
thing but
bangs all right I like that and then the
other angle is like CU a girl I'm dating
she sent me a picture of uh the haircut
she's getting but it was on Charlie
Theon oh I'm like well that's not that's
great I mean you're pretty but that's
not fair yes like I'm I'm trying on a
bathing suit I'm not I'm not sending you
a pick of Channing Tatum wearing it I'm
I'm like in this bathing suit I have abs
right well it's like those you buy
boxers and the guy on the [__] front
looks like you know uh Helmsworth and
you're like what what are you doing to
me yeah I don't look like that right
right that's why was against these
plus-sized models but I'm like yeah I'm
like I could look better than that ah
true she look that good you feel better
a woman in this joke but
uh but uh I think he got something there
yeah maybe something there you know it's
like hey I'm getting four-wheel drive
and you show your friend a photo of like
a Rolls-Royce and you're like you have a
a focus you know come
on yeah man yeah I got I got a peeve I'm
I'm with a peeve hold on you did two
bits I'm doing another bit all right
maybe we'll do bits at the end again too
my friend is uh he's always like sex
worker come on sex worker these are
hookers what are we doing here I love
hookers but I'm not calling them sex
workers I'm like you should be embracing
this because you've been called a creep
and a and a sicko your whole life now
it's
legitimized yeah it's a time where like
being anti-pc isn't doing you any favors
exactly yeah now you're helping small
business you know now you're an ally
before you were creep yeah I'm yeah
exactly and it sound I I help the sex
worker that sounds better than I [__]
The Prostitute that's the great Point
great Point yeah you're keeping these
women afloat you're a benefactor a boner
Factor all right it is weird how you
read these stories about some of these
only fans people and they you know
they're like I used to be a teacher
making like 40 Grand a year and I made a
million dollars on only fans last year
and you're like yeah I mean schools
can't really compete with you showing
your [__] I guess that's like you know
what we need is a class to teach only
fans yeah you know women will come in
and learn how to I guess you don't
really need a class to go click let's be
honest it's pretty easy yeah it's funny
they're saying like you're taking the
easy way I'm like yeah well they're
[__] crushing I guess I don't know is
having a successful only fans sort of
like going lottery in the
NBA like well what do you mean Lottery
oh like uh like you're an early pick an
early pick draft no because a lot of
these people have like a regular job and
then they do it I think like NBA you're
like kind of you're doing you know
you're doing that for years you're not
like you're not 14 like I'm prepping for
my [__] only fans saying it's 50
million to one like you're not going to
make the NBA or you're not going to make
a great successful only fan I think this
is an unfair comparison because people
who play professional sports for a
living have to work much harder and have
much more talent I think that's a that's
a ridiculous comparison to be like I got
[__] by my neighbor on camera and
you're like yeah LeBron's the gym all
off season you know what I mean and you
can be a fat lady on only fans and
that's a fetish you can still make some
money even if you're you know not
traditionally hot yeah you could look
like Jason Kelce
yes wo I wonder how B stavos is having a
moment big footb my God it's so cool I
love it it makes me [__] happy like
cuz it is cool when you're a bigname
comedian now and you're a fan of a team
that doesn't really like they're not a
like a sexy team Baltimore yeah yeah but
they do win I mean they won two Super
Bowls in the last 20 years but like 22
years whatever but
um I'm a Knicks fan we got a lot of
famous Knicks fans you know what I mean
but like say you're fan like Ian
carmell's a fan of the Blazers uhhuh he
gets hooked up with the Blazers oh
that's true you know might as well go
for it yeah I have a question for you
guys that's great this is the very first
world question this is me this is so
James Webb my friend was like I want to
go to a Knicks game this week go let's
go to a Nick game so they're playing the
Nets is that bar Clays the garden will
take care of us a little bit because we
we play their venues bar Clays it is
hard to ask because I've asked for
tickets before for the Liberty but I
root for the Liberty I as my tour
manager asked for tickets to the Knicks
Nets but I'm rooting for the Knicks is
that a dick move interesting I might
have to just buy the tickets and and
maintain my freedom of speech yeah it's
like you used to bang this lady but your
friends with her her ex are your friends
with boyfriend and they're getting
married like I want to go to the wedding
but who are you rooting for here I'm
roting for the Knicks I'm wearing a
[__] wal Frasier shirt here yeah I
yes this isn't Elaine Orioles moment but
but the problem is they're both New York
teams but I should just buy tickets I
think that's the classier thing to do
yeah but I think it's okay you know
Manhattan guy you're going for the
Knicks I I think my reputation I think
in my bio it says Nicks fan on social
media so if they look and they're like
[__] this guy yeah but yeah it's two New
York teams you should be able to rip a
team I get three tickets the answer is
no probably you're probably right the
answer is no so I think I just answered
my own question ah hate paying for [__]
what does the ticket go for 250 oh jeez
um no it's more it's a nck it's going
for more than that okay I'll get the
free
[Laughter]
tickets well all right we'll see never
set foot in the bar Clays have you guys
yeah I've never been in yeah I've seen
uh I saw the killers there I've been to
a Nicks Nets game there before I've been
a few Jeremy Lynn came to the comedy
seller once and he would he played for
the Nets so he would hook me up with
Nicks I would only ask for when they
play the Knicks but he would hook it up
oh that's awkward uh I know it is
awkward cuz me and my brother are there
in like Ying jerseys and he's like
thanks where the hell has he been Yu no
Lynn Lynn he's playing overseas I think
oh okay he was on a championship team
with the Raptors all right go Canada
so H me with a peeve okay I got wait did
you do another bit you did right I did
yeah me with a peeve all right peeve it
is baby coming at you coming it hot
dreads on Jeremy Lynn by the way yeah he
got called out for that by Kenya Martin
who I love Kenya Martin's also an ex
Nick called him out for that but then
Kenya Martin has Chinese tattoos on him
so Lynn kind of made a comment like
maybe we're just celebrating each
other's culture good that's an UNO card
reverse holy [__] wow all right uh all
right how about this you got the guy I
this I got three of them so I I'll take
it easy here uh first off I'm in
Indianapolis I'm staying in the hotel
for some reason everyone in the hotel is
coming to my show so it's just up and
down all day in the elevator do the show
show was great Indie was fun great crowd
hung I go out drinking hung over the
next day to go get my to the airport in
the elevator with like four big guys who
are at the show Disney on Ice is across
the street at the Pacers arena so
there's all kinds of kids at the show
too so now that's a great thing for you
to be competing against too because that
they're not eaten of the Mark Norman
tickets good point good point pedophile
I don't know but I'm in the elevator
with like six kids tiny kids this you
they just look up at you and stare and
then I got three mukes from Indie or or
or the greater Indianapolis area and
they're all going oh [__] a comedy
what a [__] good time [__] yeah that
[__] show is awesome you really [__]
in their faces baby and these kids are
like and I don't want to be the square
like easy around the kids but there's
six kids and three guys just screaming
and cursing it was awkward you got to
dial that back yeah and the parents are
looking at me like who are you a cult
leader what the hell's going on here so
that was badua your career yeah yeah he
look God love that doesn't happen to
Nate barazi they just they just come in
like great show that's true that's true
no one's at Seinfeld like you [__]
homo get over here your fans come in I'm
gay they're like what is going on free
all [__] woo so those poor kids were
traumatized that is rough it is rough
when it's uh I've been that drunk guy at
a sporting event with the kids around
yeah and you're like yeah I got to tone
this down this isn't if it's kids around
yeah yeah and you know do what you got
to do but they all the parents looked at
me like what are you what what are you
bringing on my kids here all right how
about this one that's a good peeve okay
you get the guy who text you this just a
random text out of the blue hey man and
you're like huh just is hey man what's
that about so then I I go hey and he
goes can you do this and you're like
just hit me with the question don't give
me the Heyman trap and then I respond
back and then you hit me he he hit me
like that's a great it's great
observation because now you're on the
line I'm on the hook yeah it's it's
almost as bad as asking to your face oh
because once you get the
response you're obligated to respond of
course of course he he knows it's kind
of he knows you're there so if you don't
respond it's like I don't have the red
receipts on for a reason yeah and now
you're it's almost as if I have them on
exactly it's pretty Shifty I want to
reply my sometimes I see something I'm
like all right I'll respond to this
later if it's like a loaded text but ooh
comic uh Booker I have to call you out
though because you had a peeve I don't
know months ago where it was like
someone just said hey man can you do
this show this show this show and you're
like how about it how you doing oh
interesting all right but I think I
think this is how he really feels what
are you what are you his girlfriend
bringing up his
P I see what you're saying no I see what
you're saying too but I do think that
you can say that how you're doing in the
same test yes there you go I think
that's the real issue is is say uh hey
man how you doing been a while like hope
something pleasant and then in the same
line so now he's not obligated I also
think some of those questions are almost
better done over email oh yeah yeah you
can space it out a little bit because a
long text is daunting you see that long
horizontal thing and you're like oh God
but an email it just feels like a
paragraph but also not to challenge you
but I think that Heyman thing was in
person I had a guy just walk right up me
go can I do the show
but if you go hey man how are you then
ask but the text he pulled me in with
the hey man singular text does bug me
you got any peeves cuz I got one more if
you don't yeah I got some peeves all
right all right make sure I guest in
messag us too oh yeah New York one
please please so when you're waiting for
the subway and you see now there's like
the Chiron up on the screen tells you
when the next trains are love the Chiron
I love it but it's like next F train 16
minutes yeah the one after that 17
minutes I I am with you 100% [__] I know
a little bit yeah I'm with you like the
text but uh no I'm with you but I'll
tell you another one that annoys me 16
minutes next one 41 minutes I'm like
what is this yeah NBC Thursday's comedy
lineup how how far you going to spread
this out all right I got another one
piggybacking on this okay now this is
really specific okay you might have to
pull one up for the fans because I don't
know if anyone's going to it says
one 14 minutes second train 18 minutes
third train it tells you 1 two three 4
they never show two they go one 16
minutes three 80 minutes four 90 minutes
I'm like what happened to two yeah what
is that is are they showing two sides I
don't I don't know what they're doing oh
maybe that's it but yeah this is really
specific but isn't it crazy that just a
mere few years ago we had no Chiron
underground and we had no cell phone
service Underground I know so we were
rocking and rolling with our thoughts
and just praying to God a train Camp all
you head was this I remember seeing the
Departed in movie theaters and uh and
Leo in one scene is on the phone on the
train and I was like that's [__]
[__] I remember thinking that see
look at that goes it skips two it does
that all the time one to three what
happened to three I might and now you're
just now you're like a gambling guy
you're just hoping two is okay yeah yeah
you're like come on Daddy needs a new
pair of tracks oh man I I got a peeve
really shitty hotel gyms cuz we live on
the road I I the pull-up bar is too high
I do one I'm going to put my head
through the [__] ceiling I've had the
same thing really poorly thought out
ones and you know like you should have
the base I'm not looking for like a five
star setup here but have the basic [__]
yes give me the 50 lb dumbbell and under
give me the bench give me the treadmill
give me the pull-up bar yeah that's all
I need I'm easy and they don't all have
a pull-up bar so when you see it it's
like a tease it is a tease I got oh now
I'm going through the tile here yeah now
you're like [__] I got another one all
right these are good this is a basic one
it is a peeve
hiccups [__] hate it oh I hate
hiccups I got bad hiccups the other day
I hadn't had them in like I feel like
years and they wouldn't go away it was
like never do and and you know what got
rid of them I had a sugar packet really
granulated sugar oh yeah I didn't even
know I had him in the apartment what are
you doing you just swallow it really and
I shot a load of my chest but you know
but yeah know I had some of the sugar
and uh it helped but it wouldn't go away
forever and
uh oh [__] it's the worst it's the worst
like idiot the longest case of hiccups
years 60 that's rough wow cuz that's Su
no one wants to hang out with you either
yeah so you're just like the [__]
hiccup guy imagine
proposing marrying the woman and then
the next day and she's like oh great you
get into a fight you're like you never
listen you [__] my best
friend oh man that is brutal 60 years
that's a curse that's like a hex yeah
it's a curse yeah I hate having hiccups
I hate seeing hiccups I don't even like
watching the guy have them and here's
the worst part about hiccups everybody's
got a cure that doesn't work oh you got
the hiccups I got you buddy I'm going to
scare the [__] out of you you have
herpes you got hiccups I got you buddy
hold your breath chug of water jerk me
off whatever it is I'll phone for the
jerk you off thing a couple times but it
works does that's how I cured them
yeah all right last peeve and then I'll
leave you guys alone all right I'm
getting sick of the you know I'm I'm a
middle-aged queef you know I'm an old
man I'm getting a little sick of the guy
who hates another guy just cuz he's
better than him you know you go uh
talking to a talking to a dude and I go
boy that uh that Bill Johnson's a
good-looking guy and he goes oh yeah
yeah he's a really handsome guy he's
like 6'2 built and he goes you know what
[__] Bill Johnson like someone's been
hanging out with doosa
ah well it just feels a little little
hack NE and easy like oh this guy's
great in a bunch of ways that I'm not
[__] him you hang out with people who
drink too much that's why yeah maybe
you're right Bill Johnson's working he's
going to the gym he's working on himself
you're hanging out with a guy who's just
firing back tequila like [__] [__]
right [__] hate that guy I don't get
that mentality like he's doing better
than me well then I hate him now like
how about you hate yourself I don't know
you go
no I totally know the type of guy you're
talking about and uh like he didn't do
it like he it's just when you when
you're still bitter at a certain age
it's tough to be around exactly just
accept the situations accept yourself
yeah or or turn it inward oh I got to I
got to step it up you know we saw it a
lot in early days of Comedy hey Bob got
a Netflix special oh [__] bob well Bob's
better than you maybe how about
that yeah I think when you just you just
can't [__] think like that in any in
any facet of your life for you're [__]
like I mean we we were [__] angry but
we fueled it we we Ed it as fuel we
[__] we [__] and uh but you know
you definitely uh it's easy to fall into
that trap if you don't watch yourself
and if you don't have friends who who
call you out for it right right cuz you
don't want to I remember Bill Burr once
said to me he goes don't ever [__] be
the bitter guy no one wants to be around
that guy it's it's like a [__] fish
that stink it follows you it's kind of
like having hiccups you know it's uh no
it's [__] it's bad completely agree
bber had the best advice he was uh doing
some show he was opening for a guy oh I
can't remember the guy's name he's super
funny Boston Legend guy Don Gavin no no
he's in a bunch of movies he's a big
actor CL no no fat kind of fat guy
really funny ah [__] Tony V yeah I can't
believe I pulled that out of my ass Tony
V and they're sitting there smoking
cigars after a show Bill there he is
Bill Burr looks up to this guy he's
obsessed with this guy and Bill Burr is
smoking a cigar and he's feeling pretty
confident and he goes yeah you know Tony
all this network and I'm a real comic I
don't like to network and Schoo and I
hate all that [__] and you know I'm just
GNA write good jokes and [__] [__] [__]
networking and Tony ve goes get good at
it and he goes I'm just not good at it
he goes then do it and he was like oh
[__] you're right like instead of just
bitching about it and it is kind of a
part of the business so just I know you
don't want to but go get good at it
that's it that's a good point I remember
uh by the way I remember just made me
think of a story I was on my birthday
Veo and I were smoking cigars outside
the cellar one night and David tell
comes from behind me and he goes you had
a good set but it wasn't that good
oh reality check great [__] great
thing oh man this make sound a little
naive uh explain the difference between
what bur is and bitter because I I don't
think what do you mean his comedy is
like you know what I hate dude it's like
a lot of that I mean it's I'm
diminishing a little bit it's highly
elevated that's that's an act we're
talking about in real life Oh I thought
you talking about talk I mean off stage
that I think people forget and this goes
for any career you choose I think is you
just want to be somewhat Pleasant to be
around so people want you around I mean
there are Comics who Mark and I think
are hilarious that we wouldn't want to
tour with just because of their [__]
personalities totally and that's almost
more important than your act the same oh
sorry I thought that was our guest the
same with the feature like a lot of guys
can I open for you and I think this
guy's not bad but can I hang out with
this [__] for a
weekend Green Room lunches drinks
airplane the whole thing good movie so
yeah it's uh it's a big part of it a lot
of this business is hanging out talking
shooting the [__] chopping it up
trashing people and you were always a
good hang yeah you got always were a
good hang yeah I mean that it's
important especially when you're young
too it's like I remember opening for
people Young like I'll watch their set
I'll be like oh I have a tag for you if
if that's you know you not want to
disrespect them if you accept tags I
came up with the angle for this or maybe
another line but I think a lot of comics
are just like you know I'm going to do
my own thing I'm going to get drunk in
the Green Room yeah yeah you know and uh
it's good to it's good to care it is and
to show you care totally I think there
became a period where it became cool to
not care in like the Hipster rooms it
was like you go up there and you don't
give a [__] and you're like here's some
new [__] [__] I thought of you're like
read you know you almost do better when
you're you you just go you have to go in
those rooms you have to read your a
material off of the set list all new
you're like some [__] I was kicking
around it's my closer uh it's all
defense because you can't fail if you
didn't try exactly and it's all
fear-based but it became cool to not try
and it's like Mark and I used to talk
about this like would these rooms
respect George Carlin who's almost doing
a monologue up there right and it's so
finely tuned would they be cool with
that totally they'd be like man this
guy's trying too hard I know and all the
comics they like Paton Oswalt and Maria
Bamford these people busted their ass
and worked hard and wrote and got up and
did the road so like they're trying I
know you worship them but they tried so
maybe you should try yeah but yeah you
were always very professional too like
you were always trying to not be in
people's way I was more of a mess no I
thought you were good man I thought you
were you were uh we all made mistakes I
mean I remember when I missed Amy
Schumer's tour bus that was [__] yeah
she
detail cuz it was like a college gig
where she needs security this was like
train wreck she was white hot huge and
uh yeah and I missed just as Mark tells
me I was professional I was drinking
with one of her brother's band mates in
the room and I missed the car and I'm in
like Nike High Tops I can't run in these
shits I'm sprinting after a tour bus and
she was not happy with me oh yeah you
look like a psychoan chasing the bus Amy
I love
you yeah yeah I mean but to me you know
she obviously pulled over eventually but
that's kind of a
lesson she didn't pull over they had to
pull over like a gas station I had to
get a ride oh is that it was not it was
a low point for me I was not pleased
with myself yeah cuz no one gives a [__]
how well you do on stage as an opener if
you make mistakes like that true so I I
I learned a lesson yeah well there you
go but uh guys that with um other Comics
saying like I don't watch other
comedians I don't do that I get it
because you don't want to absorb their
material but uh you got you got to find
a line right yeah to me what's weirder
is when you're like you ever seen that
you ever seen bring the pain they're
like nah never caught bring the pain I'm
like yeah I get if you don't watch the
new guys or The Late Late Late stuff but
you got to watch some of the legendary
great specials yeah it's like being a
filmmaker and not watching like
Tarantino or or [__] scorsi or like
Woody Allen or you know Spike any of
these like Classic Movies you're not
going to watch these I know I know
exactly but hey everybody's got their
[__] but I also just like standup I
like comedy so I'm like oh Gary
gold uhoh very happy to have this guy
back and we got your root beer as well
yeah what Shak this is Matt how are you
buddy good to see you n what you what
you FaceTiming oh that's thing oh oh
okay I thought you had a hot Asian lady
on on the hook there oh Dolly Parton oh
yeah she's hot she's always been a hot
where did you stand on the uh on the
halftime show in the Bikini oh the
cheerlead out that's how I feel listen
man first of all Thanksgiving yeah she
did she in a Dallas Cowboy cheerleading
suit she came and saying pull it up I
think she's I think Dolly can do however
the [__] she wants go Dolly working
925 what a way to make a
living hell yeah hell yeah I think she's
about 95 she's 95 she's got to be up
there she's oh she's about
95 she's barely
living she looks amazing she looks great
no work done at all no and you know
she's work she's been married the same
guy for since the 60 like for like 40 50
years wow Dollywood is worth $500
million she written the songs that she's
leased out like I Will Always Love You
yep is that's Whitney H that's Dolly
part wrote it wow she wrote a lot of
songs and she leases them out and she
said I'm just all about the money I
don't give a damn you can sing whatever
you want just pay me hell yeah cuz I
watched interview with her with uh Dan
Rather Jesus you know what AIS TV Mark
Cuban's Channel I remember did we all
did that show didn't we I I never did it
oh okay I almost did I want to host it I
didn't want to [__] go spot there
yeah but yeah I was at Gotham remember
the Gotham thing so I uh watched Dan
Rather had a little show where he would
interview I've watched Merl Haggard wow
wow yeah I watched the whole Merl hagard
interview Merl Hager was a prisoner when
Johnny Carson did Fon pris Johnny Cash
Sor Johnny Carson Johnny Cash Johnny
Caron W this
a ha Bill Cosby did Fon prison blue that
it's like hello this is Bill C Welcome
to the prison of full
wow but Merl had you could have done a
stand up special in prison it would have
been kind of interesting that would have
that would have broke the internet pull
your pants
up don't drop the
soap but I uh um Merl Haggard was an
inmate when Johnny Carson was recording
Johnny [__] what is wrong with Johnny
Cash was doing that um album hagard was
in it was an inmate yeah and when he
goes hello I'm Johnny Cash and Merl
Haggard got influenced to do music when
he saw Johnny Cash so that does it does
do good when you when you Johnny Cash
did uh San Quinton and Fon prison he was
a bad [__] I I did comedy in a
prison once really yeah in Chicago
enough about hot comedy
club we did it was Dixon State ped it
was like in Illinois when I was it was
only I was only like two years in the
comedy who and my friend was like hey
man you want to do a prison I said like
like The Blues Brothers like [__]
like like uh Johnny Cash he goes yeah I
say [__] yeah I can just have a story so
we did it we it was maximum security
men's and maximum security women's so we
had to separate shepher shows whoa yeah
that [__] was interesting and it was
like you you they have a stage they have
performance like an auditorium and they
there and [__] man it was like the men's
you know and there's like sedated side
where these people are like drugs and
they're just sitting there and then
there's the wild [__] going yo
talk about that [__] right now
and the warden is sitting up at the at
the top there's uh these tears and
there's guards with guns all over and
you're doing you really hope they don't
have to use those yeah yeah right right
and they were
like they were like talk about the war
that fat [__] I was like hey
they called you a fat [__] and
they're like it was laughing yeah Warden
just sitting there yeah whatever they
locked the [__] up they're not but these
guys are murderers [__] like that yeah
no one's getting offended by Jes yeah
there was one of my one of my buddies on
there his name is Kenny how he knew a
lot of guys in prison he was like this
oh man what's up man too bad you ain't
getting out God damn he would like make
fun of these guys I was like [__] yeah
oh yeah so and then we did the second
show was women's yeah all women's prison
and I was like asking and it were like
hot chicks in there like so what
happened you yeah I uh shot my boyfriend
while he was sleep cuz he used to beat
on me and [__] so it was [__] like that
it's like the movie Chicago or something
right right but you're like you're like
a superstar to them yeah so I've done
that is the most elaborate porno of all
time comedian plays women's prison izy
yeah [__] yeah that was that was my we
went from Dolly Parton and what the [__]
but Dolly Parton's been always been hot
though I think I agree
yes what what is she 85 78 I think what
is she what is she now what is Dolly
Parton 7 yeah probably close to 80 maybe
what we got a lot of range on this 78 a
young a young yeah I looked it up cuz I
was like what's the oldest woman of
jacked off to so probably her right
probably yeah good cleavage goodle
cleavage Dolly Parton held herself up
pretty well and then when she talks she
just so happy for she's just a positive
lady and still going like Mariah Carey
made all that Christmas money she's
sitting on her fat ass in Hollywood she
is working she's still TOS doesn't she
or no I think she still does some stuff
well that Nick Cannon really banged her
out so you've never seen a picture of
her arms I've heard she sleeved up who
Dolly no way you talking tattoos
tattoos has tattoos I think they're all
over her arms full swasa they said Mr
Rogers had tattoos really that's
hilarious in in the do they swimming I
don't think he had tattoos Fred did Fred
Rogers ever have tattoos interest you
got any I have a half sleeve right here
what really did I show you yeah whatever
can you get all that you look like
you're dressed for a funeral in the
future Demolition Man over here triple
X oh [__] man let's see I don't know it'
be great if he had a [__] stamp I think
this myth is busted yeah in the dock
they showed him swimming I would have
wow look at that who God you're pretty
[__] rip man that's cool is that like
a tribal my parents past I had the
Nigerian that's my tribe that I'm from
it's EO tribe which is funny because
there's EO Jews in ain't that
crazy yo but um yeah and this is like
Tonga from Tonga like South Pacific sh
so I surrounded him with that but yeah I
have half sleep I never had tattoo
before but I wanted to do that and it
was pain dude Jonathan major is out of a
part maybe you could slide into that
[__] wak man right a cool character I
know [__] but I don't know man I think
hey show an African mask okay lot of
range Dolly to to
Nigeria I think um you everyone's
talking about you know you saw the Cat
Williams interview know of course I saw
your Steve Harvey
responds so good you're [__] good at
that man I mean it's all St Steve Harvey
I mean yeah where did you stand on the
on the Cat Williams interview cuz he
took down so many people it was it was a
it was an incredible ugly storm it was
Fant and you know when he talks he he
sucks you in he's captivating cuz he's
like and I told you man and I
said [__] you're like like a
preacher like a one of those what is
they what are those people when those
people would go from town to Town the
snake oil what is it snake oil sales
snake oil sales come on hurry hurry we
got
that's magic potion I'm telling you this
magic potion you [__] never to
drink this are you dying and suffering
froma what the well listen let me tell
you something lady I know you need this
[__] this is the most magical [__] ever
I am Cat Williams [__] and I'm
bringing you magical [__] and You' be
like yeah I bu that he's that kind of
guy elixir right whether he was lying or
not he was it was so entertaining and to
see and and to see uh Shannon sharp
going skip oh man come on I can't
believe this man I thought y was
together oh damn I went skip with play
shanon play shanon Sharp's laugh oh yeah
it's it's the funnest It's the funniest
laugh I've ever heard he's so country
too I don't think I could listen to a
shanon sharp interview unless it was Cat
Williams steamrolling him for two and a
half hours I think that's the only way I
could could have handled
it oh wow that laugh is [__]
insane damn it's like the hyena and Lion
King wow fantastic did y'all see this
SNL parody it was really funny no the
girl did it oh my god wow this is really
that's dead on they nailed the
set3 wood created Kevin Hart everybody
knows that Kevin was made in the same
Factory they make Teddy Graham that
came Teddy grah dude pull up Cat
Williams running the the the 40 cuz Cat
Williams everyone's like he can't run R
he's [__] fast he ran like a four
what did he because he goes I can run a
42 yeah he's like no man K come on K
that's impossible K this is pretty
impressive that's impossible kall stuff
like that so L Mo went there he know he
has eight kids has like eight or 10 look
at this wow oh no find the find the real
like the fast one where he's like really
there it is there it is yeah cat is
hilarious he really is cat is so he's
such a Tripp damn he is
[Music]
fast he's beating he ran at a 447 that's
pretty [__] good and he's 50 whatever
he R A
447 wow that is fast that's like wide
receiver speed like right on the be
great AR If he if he just played Cat
Williams played in the NFL next year
ah who's that is that Cedric
no 1.3 oh that's funny he got he and
what's funny is can we show Cedric
stealing a joke from a sitcom I saw that
meak Taylor m tayl a black actor who
passed away he was on a show called
Designing Women I never watched it but
it was a hit show Delta B that's right
uh you should so show that and it's and
cat was right Cedric took a joke from a
goddamn sitcom I know and it wasn't a
great joke either no it wasn't I was
like and I know C ced's always been
great comic and I was just it's not good
and cat cat's literally cleaning house
man oh he's cleaning house Mark made a
great point though cat is he's starting
up a tour I mean is there any more
brilliant way to do this is what I heard
I heard like some of his tour the the
tickets weren't really selling as well
and then did that and that [__] sold out
to the Moon we go watch
this telling the bom story it's a true
story see there was this white family
lived in Mississippi and they had this
man who worked for them occasionally
named binici now he did various small
jobs for them on and off for about a
week like you just finished bartending
the party and the lady of the house
realized that she didn't have any money
so she said to him binici I I want to
write you a chair yeah but I I don't
know how to spell
bomin he said well I've been meaning to
talk to you about that see when I came
to work for you I told you my name and
then I said but you can call me by my
initials everybody call you
bomin man city call bom don't even worry
about it's fine you call don't it's just
such an obscure premise that's why yeah
everybody call me that man don't worry
about that and then he's like no one's
going to catch me Designing Women come
on Cat Williams
I think part of the other stuff is like
it's like [__] it does feel like it's
often the swaggiest comics that get cuz
it's like you're like he's so confident
right a [__] Fedora he's not stealing
and another thing too is not is the
comics that you know that don't really
work on their [__] a lot if I don't see
you touring you're either doing a oneman
show or you're stealing some [__] yeah
because you you you're always working
your [__] out I see you guys we're all
getting off stage going here and there
we work our [__] out in between the
tours
always Ching that's what we do I see the
work you know but these guys they're on
sitcoms they're and then they just go oh
I'm going to put a show together right
and then they start taking [__] you know
and I know some other big Comics that
are [__] thieves go [__] yourself you
[__] thieves yeah listen I've done a
joke where I go oh wow someone had a
similar but there's certain jokes we've
all made mistakes when you burn enough
hours there's going to be parallel
subjects where every comic is going to
go there it's like SNL yeah they did a
parody of it was already a give it was a
give it was like a godsend you know
here's you if you [__] this up SNL right
I don't know what to tell you you know
what I mean it's like one of those
things where yeah we're going to go
there everybody's going to go and do
that with that subject it's easy you
know what I mean but did you see the
Steve Harvey Mark Curry let's do that
and I love Mark Cur Mark Curry called
[__] I love hanging with Mr Cooper as a
kid was like my [__]
when I knew and Mark Curry I knew when
he was in during when I was a um an
amateur comedian Mark Curry would come
to Chicago was the nicest guy till this
day and he was the he was massive oh
yeah and he was still the coolest dude
sit there talk to you forever love it
Harvey was like kind of a a dick yeah
Harvey was he's always the thing is
Harvey's never really changed he's
always been kind of a yeah what's up now
yeah okay yeah
uhhuh I'm just tell you right now I got
time for that
bush but Steve has always been like now
he has m a lot of money now so it's like
worse got it yeah that doesn't help it
usually and that man unit he really got
called out for that I thought I was like
wow who's his Barber how the [__] does
he get that I was like man and I was
like I want that Ste that [__] fake
and it was fake thank
God Jamie Fox has a little bit of that
too he has it too his [__] is fake oh
yeah oh his hairline goes back here
really foxes know Cat Williams did clean
house that was the black Epstein
list but Mark Curry was such a gifted
comic actor I mean like elevated that
material you know and you see him now is
he's still brilliant as [__] man you
know he had an accident no it's like a
fire I think he was in a sort of a real
[__] up accident so he's recovered but
he's like been traveling with Cat
Williams on his tours and I was watching
some of he's [__] amazing oh
C Yeah clean and he's really a skill and
he's from Oakland so people thought he
was just this clean cut little [__] guy
n no he's he's the he's the real deal oh
yeah but he's just a nice guy but he's
he he's called okay play that what about
Steve Harvey play that yeah watch this
watch show so I had a beef on that he
did all my Halloween material one
Halloween I'm watching and I know he
didn't think of it you know this this is
true stuff that really happened to me
and so my thing is you didn't have to do
that homeboy so you know mother you made
enough money [__]
ass uh I think the bit was he said uh I
didn't have enough money to get a
costume so my dad just gave me UPS boxes
you want to show that I think you
stepped on the punch up there man I've
been watching everything yeah same it's
it's nice when they show the side by
side because it's you know to really put
people on blast I think you know it's
called receipts there you go there it is
guys and before the internet it was a
lot easier to get away with it yeah yeah
oh [__] yeah man Robin Williams I can
tell you the story Robin Williams Ry
Romano [__] at the seller as Ray Romano
got off stage I was hosted [__] was it
was [__] Ray was going up the stairs
and Robin Williams goes on right after
he does this like this um Xerox joke and
Robin did the same one was in the
hallway and did it he was so in him to
do that what did it bomb really was like
they were confused just goes upstairs
and I was like sitting there in the
hallway was I with SD and I was
like Robin is like he he couldn't help
it yeah yeah cuz Robin used to hang with
us eat wings with us table the comedy
table and I'd be like hey what's up man
he goes oh you know I'm just working out
some things I have you know I uh I have
a I have to host the Oscars so I just
want to work the ni the Nic dude but
think with a guy like Robin I think this
is my take on it and I could be wrong
but it seems like you become you're on a
rocket ship you're so famous you're
grabbing [__] you're like I need this so
people think I'm still funny I'm not
making an excuse it's [__]
unacceptable but I think that's in and
like I think the same goes for these
guys you know but you can't [__] do
it you just can't you know Robin stole
one of Richard Jenny's things I killed
himself all right yo speaking of Richard
it's so funny man when you're around oh
that's the that's the other Cedric joke
that that one's crazy okay watch this
one very egregious all right all right
okay damn we got a lot we got a lot to
talk about so there's there's there's
Cat Williams and Cedric
stealing Cat Williams the the SP this
one yes okay Cat Williams talking about
like parking a car what are they
thinking stealing from cat and this bit
is so elaborate
too
comedy he sits down cigarette and
everything God he just the same joke
doesn't line up I this is a televised
joke feels that uh someone else has
stolen some of your material oh that
that's a part of this business like
Steve that went my favorite part of this
interview myv intervie is how cat keeps
bringing it back to football he's like
have you have you ever dropped the pass
not everything is haven't you made
enemies with the Dallas Cowboys and he
go like but that's different C that's
not the same
thing those my friends C come on man but
the
best somebody's like he's like he's like
stealing bit have you ever run the same
route that's not the same that's not
it's not the same thing it's not the
same thing bad
analogy but I but I love what he's doing
because cat's so confident and that I'm
like I'm just like listening like yeah
I'm rolling with it cuz he's so he's
like aor there's some [__] being
said but you believe it exactly got that
Kennon had cuz Kennison was also I think
he started as a [__] dud let me tell
you kenison is so great I I watched
Kennison in his first time on Letterman
I watch it over and over he has his coat
button up to here that [__] weird
hairstyle aw he's like how you guys
doing all right used to be a p and and
then he just start oh he's so good it
broke the format you never saw a guy do
a comedy set like that yeah he changed
up the whole game but yeah um I think
the what's the you saw the Cat Williams
one did we do
the the the car ups and Steve Harvey and
UPS watch this one is and then stole
everything Mark we show UPS Steve Harvey
ups and Mark Curry joke a whistle Mark
I'm teaching music not Jim no what's
this standard issue this might be
another one screaming for help kids no
it's a joke you okay watch uh Mark Curry
UPS joke just look up Mark you'll see
with Steve har they got everything oh
yeah oh yeah that one's dead on when you
do the side to side oh if you're a fan
of the show you're probably also a fan
of not having a sweaty dick she
underwear can get you that not sweaty
dick of your dreams in no time you know
what I bet I'm wearing it right now and
this isn't plan I don't know what we're
reading when I get boom
sheath love it love sheath here's a
secret there two pouches one for your
dick one for your balls it keeps stuff
separated down there so things don't get
all stuck together and suction cup to
your thigh I love it I honestly wear it
every day my lady loves it I wear it
gets her all moist sheath underwear was
made by US Army Sergeant Robert Padden
to handle the heat of the Iraqi desert
so you can feel like a patriot when
you're doing this [__] too you can keep
your balls and your dick cool there and
it can do anything give it a shot and
get the best underwear you'll ever put
on truly my favorite I mean I look I'm
I'm bullshitting some of these ads here
some of these I don't give a [__] I
really do like this stuff I wear it uh
go to sheath underwear. comom and use
the code drunk to get 20% off your first
order plus sheath underwear is 100% back
money sorry 100% money back guarantee
that sheath underwear. comom promo code
drunk get sheath underwear support the
show support your balls remember the
last time you were at the gas station
and saw those horribly branded erection
pills did you ever take a second to see
what's actually in those products
they're bad for you believe it or not
I'm shock too they seem healthy enter
Joy mode their sexual performance
booster enhances sex drive and blood
flow resulting in a better performance
it's natural it's science-backed sexual
Wellness supplement for men take their
sexual performance booster before
getting down and dirte to support
erection quality firmness and sex drive
created by best-in-class scientists this
is the science we need and PhD
biochemist the sexual performance
booster contains clinically supported
doses of Argan nitrate L Citron panex
ginsing and vitamin C for that vitamin D
you need this stuff it's going to help
uh look if you have problems no big but
do you really want it to affect your
life you need you need to have your
penis and if it's a big part of unless
you're a pedophile then don't take this
don't don't don't do it yeah sorry Mark
but just tear open a packing mix it with
five to eight ounces of water drink it
anywhere from 45 minutes to 4 hours
before sex if you really plan that's a
[__] planner right there watch the
magic unfold go to use jooy mode.com
drunk and get 20% off with code drunk
and checkout that's 20% off and fre free
shipping with code drunk at
usej ym
o.com drunk great sex solve naturally
nice magic unfold how big is your dick
where you're unfolding it um is it is it
busted busted four years ago though
damn but it was still it was him right
there next Steve Harvey watch Halloween
was a trip Halloween we couldn't afford
no Halloween costumes hey kids please
Mama sent us down to the liquor store
put boxes on
us we didn't know what we were I don't
know what we
are I don't know she didn't tell
her I think we UPS I guess I don't know
you heard me say that every Halloween I
had the same outfit on every
year I just had a brown box oh man I was
nothing sad just not asked my father
could I have a new outfit and he said no
just wear the same one it was just a
brown box and he just told me to tell
everybody I was a UPS man uh okay so
tell me so it's just a it's like there's
parallel thinging but that is like his
childhood but he this is Steve Harvey on
his 18th show that he's hosed right and
he's loaded and is like I'm [__]
touring with Cat Williams opening up and
I was on a big why would you do that to
me like but there's I know guys that
still do it now damn that will take a
comic that is not famous and oh I'm
gonna go to this open mic and just just
[__] yeah at least pay the guy right
hey man I like that I heard Williams
would do that yeah take a well I think
Robin Williams did it after someone like
punched him in a face oh J Moore as well
J Moore stole right he stole from Ben
Bailey and Ben Bailey chased him down
Ben Ben will beat you up I Ben Ben body
slammed a college student at one of his
[__] GS really Ben and he's like a
legend for that Ben Ben they Ben Bailey
like body slamed some college kid
because they you know I first of all I
hate colleges I'm G I used to think
colleges would be amazing [__] no me
well when you're young you're like it's
an easy payday yeah but where they put
you you never know what college you're
going to sure they'll put you in a
[__] you know cafeteria a study hall
y you ever do an afternoon study hall
cafeteria was rough [__] yo I
remember doing a swimming pool gig that
was [__] up what it was a swimming
party and I'm looking for the state like
hope they come up for air to get your
[__] goes dude I just had a really
good idea um it's a swimming po party
I'm so happy you're here everybody's
looking forward to I go so yeah where we
going to do the show okay here it is
we're going to have the microphone right
by the swimming pool and they're going
to swim up to you that's what he did he
did this I and I [__] railed this
dude for [__] 30 minutes that was my
whole act yeah and they swam up to me in
the swimming pool and I had to do comedy
oh that's brutal it was like some
[__] Annette finello [__] I'm do
an old school [__] beach party
[__] why point at meell no no no I
didn't no I think you would know you
seem to know yeah Frank Beach Blanket
Bingo frankon Beach Blanket Bingo Beach
[__] I watched all this my mom but yeah
um the [__] was I saying I go on tangent
man my bad [__] was I talking about
Cedric Curry the swimming pool game
colleges colleges yeah Ben Bailey he
[__] slammed the body slammed I
remember telling me he goes yeah my body
slammed him you know Ben talks yeah he
goes he was [__] pissing me off and
he comes up on the stage and I go hey
you can't you can't touch this
microphone he goes I want to I want to
do and he just [__] bang and the
place went nuts like oh yeah so Ben
became this Ben Ben W Ben will fight you
he's 65 or whatever and he's no and he's
a big Irish and he doesn't [__] around
he's like that dude I've seen him get
mad at people you know at the sellers
hell yeah you know what I mean it's too
bad he never did that in Cash Cab that
he pulled it over like you got a problem
with me yeah he wed they should bring
that back that was like that's like a
machine they were going he said they
were going to bring it back yeah I had
audition for Cash Cab we all had didn't
and Ben wed Emmy and brought it to the
seller remember that oh that's great and
he beat out Jeopardy that one year damn
damn yeah he body slamed Ben is that guy
man Ben when he did I think he did um
America's Got Talent he did one of the I
think he he he did the comedy on there
uh and I did it trough and and and Heidi
Clum I think said something crazy to him
and he was like what do you
do that's Ang Ben don't [__] around B
cuz she was like oh I didn't think you
have funny he goes and what do you do
wow I think that's the greatest [__]
ever I love it she's she's at De Veer
she's like you're a little slow he's
like so are you he said that no I just
made that he hated her I know that yeah
I heard she was just but Ben is that
kind of guy you know she was pretty nice
to me that's yeah melb was pretty nice
to me Simon [__] me well that's his
whole thing yeah Mandel was very nice
how did you you what what made you want
to do that you're just trying to sell
tickets on the road no doubt no I got
you I was young and I was just trying to
move some tickets and uh and to be
honest they aired like a f minute
segment of me and I got more messages
from that it said like 10 million
viewers that's huge and uh and I
remember uh yeah I made it two first
round I got a [__] standy no I
crushed I crushed and they were like we
don't know if we're going to use use it
and I'm like that is so [__] up that I
just got a standing know for 5,000
people and you're not going to use it
like we'll see and then um the second
round I went on to late it was like I
went on at like midnight and I got there
at 10:00 a.m. and uh yeah and they were
like we're kind of uh they were like
yeah made us no different different
audience but like Simon loved me the
first round he was like that was I was
expecting to be bad and that was good
and then the second round he's like yeah
it just made me tired I'm like what is
midnight yeah right you know I mean uh
and I was like that might play a role in
it but I watched him be way more vicious
to other people like I saw these two
Jewish rappers go on and I thought they
were like kind of good he was like
you're terrible like kill yourself the I
think that's what they're he's supposed
to do with just that's just his
thing yeah yeah um comedy I don't know
how you guys I can't do contest com I
did one I feel like you could though I
feel like you you're like a hell gig
machine I feel like every time I go
every time I go to a club though every
time I go to a club no I feel like you
could just kill anywhere I mean as a
compliment I know I because when he said
gy could follow
911 that's a big ass compliment but I I
listen I think it's coming from cuz the
comic strip when comic strip was
actually cool when there was Lucian you
guys it's so funny how you been around
so long lucian's a painting
now and you got to say you knew that guy
[__] weird it's like I knew Picasso
let me
explain but it's Lucian you ever go to
have you guys even go to the comic strip
now and then I was a comic strip guy me
Tom Papa yeah we were comic strip dudes
J Freelander we were and then we started
heading downtown we would do Boston
Comedy Club Barry Kats at the Boston
Comedy Club then we I went over to the
seller trying to get in and Norton got
me in Norton got was my reference and ni
I think no was it Keith another guy got
me in and I had to wait for SD to
approve me and she kept not watching my
[__] then one day I approached her I
said hey uh SD is me again can I and she
goes oh okay listen I didn't see your
tape but listen you can I you I come
back at 12:00 you do 5 minutes okay I
said all right I came back and that's
how I got in but I would do that's an
audition a midnight you're not getm and
that's when ESD was smoking oh wow she
smoked I didn't even know she smoked oh
I can see that inside the club when
smoking was allowed and she's scary now
imagine then young smoking isra like
this wait watching you with with Manny
who owned this you know no's dad right
Manny was like the mo Manny didn't play
that [__] and when you were [__] up
they would speak in Hebrew oh when you
was trash cuz i' stand there and Manny
go what do you think about this guy and
then they'd be
like and and man but Manny was funny as
F he were like get the [__] Kane yeah
oh
a Pian wi comes behind you but then when
you did well they were like what mother
amazing and Manny was old Jewish cat
went you know Army he had a belt with a
knife in it he goes God for let me show
you something if they [__] with me this
is what they get yeah and he would click
it it a blade big ass blade in his belt
wow cuz Manny would get in scuffles with
people like like he stabbing people but
if they attack he's like he's damn I was
in the Israeli Army I let these
[__] he was funny as
[__] who about uh who else was the new
Comics there's like were you back then
for me it was okay cuz I think they knew
the seller I mean they sometimes show
the list of the people that when I was
around it was Marrin y I was host when I
would Marin it would be Todd brry Marrin
doollo O'Neal Burr when Burr hadir hair
yeah oh yeah Billy Bill Burr uh it was
uh Keith Robinson Norton uh Voss
Silverman a lot of times silver
Silverman um [__] um
classic yel uh [__] um that's a hell of
a lineup oh Russ maniv oh yeah R Russ is
funny Russ so funny Russ is one of my
favorite jokes of all time can I tell it
real EST he goes my he goes I have bad
luck with women my last four pregnant
girlfriends died in
accid that's a great joke so funny great
J was funny as [__] he i l his joke kind
of just he was like a fret dude like but
he had great jokes man he just kind I
don't know if he always liked him a lot
he was he was one of those guys that was
like goodlooking dude be on TV but he
you know when things don't really oh
Geraldo Geraldo I was around Geraldo
Geraldo um great joke Rider [__] Geraldo
there was Colin Colin of course that's
how we did um um what's the thing tough
crowd tough crowd because it was all of
us there yeah and we would all just and
it was so good cuz Manny would be there
and we would just [__] rip on each it
was just so F because they don't do that
now no cuz you guys we can all [__] with
each other that's all we did as all we
were all [__] joking on people soon
as you came up to the seller when before
they redid it yeah because the Falafel
thing was in the front
right when you first walk up that's
where you saw the make flaf the spit the
spit [__] yeah then you go up and then
Patrice would be like job of the Hut
waiting on you and they be like oh this
[__] here it's like you oh yeah
they would we would just start ragging
Voss Jim those were the main dudes that
would just start going in on you what
year was that this is
989 wow cuz you're in comedian the
documentary
must have been a trip back then cuz
Seinfield came back and started to you
know he was like I'm coming back to just
do comedy again and so he was filming
around us and he saw me I he would like
go up after me or before and I remember
he sat me down he saw me cuz I had just
come back from Egypt okay 2000 I came
back from Egypt and I I came back from
Egypt and went to the seller after I got
back I got back in the daytime I still
went down to the C to do a to about
Egypt and S was watching the whole thing
and he goes he was and he was like man
that was that's that was good man I like
the way he goes I like the way he did
the camel thing then you and you broke
it down all this [__] I was like cool
we're talking and this is sitcoms this
is
Ion and he's giving me advice on stuff
and I talking to me for an hour he's
like d and he said how long you been to
ComEd I and I was bragging I was like
yeah I'm about 9 years now now nine
years he goes okay that's kindergarten
he goes but he said let me tell you your
whatever age whatever year you are in
comedy is your age in comedy NY old
you're a dumb kindergardener right right
the best advice one of the best whatever
your age is in your year is in comedy is
your age in comedy so if you're 25 years
you're a 25y old 30 years you're a 30y
old it makes total sense so that's how I
got in cuz he his camera dudes liked me
so they were I got in it like couple two
SE yeah I remember that it's [__] the
movie so many times I know you go uh oh
you're going to go on the road now well
you've got enough yeah and you can tell
you're trying to be normal you know
you're cuz I know I know him but he
Seinfeld's very specific though if he
doesn't know you scary don't come up to
him it's [__] see I've stood there while
he someone would be like oh Jerry love
you he goes thanks a lot can I have a
picture no thanks that's what he does
yeah no thanks there's a great scene
where a guy goes Jerry I'm a huge fan
they shake hands and he goes all right I
got to go out of here but it was such a
pleasure and he goes we just shook we
don't need to shake twice and I was like
oh man I'll never ask to shake his hand
yeah that's a tough one it's also like
we've all been there though with the
drunk after the show who sh who shakes
your hand nine times toally totally we
we're like let's just kiss at this
point but and the thing is as as
performers if you to go hey dude leave
me alone that's a normal reaction yeah
but for us it's like oh yeah he was a
[__] dick no you bother me five times
and I tell them I go dude what if I did
that to you I was just it's normal to go
dude all right already I'm not being
dick I shook your hand you know but they
keep uh and one more thing and one more
thing you're like [__] you know I was at
the cell the other night and this this
guy comes up to me he's like a really
nice guy he's pissed drunk though and uh
he comes over to me and he's like hey
man I'm just I'm a fan my wife's not
doing well and I said oh come here let's
I said let's send her a video Let's I'm
being
video try to in the video a drunk waiter
from the comes behind us and
starts like his wife's got cancer you
[__] idiot trying to do a nice
thing but he was too drunk to reason
with godamn
it that's great God damn yeah man that's
the the balance of but that's good
everybody I talk to you know I do the
road whatever how' you have here lately
we had Godfrey different hour every
night I hear it too and it makes me feel
like [__]
yeah how do you do it I you know what I
think is it boredom are you just at like
the top level of the video game you're
like I got to challenge myself I never
feel the same on every show and here's
here's my weird thinking I go the one
thing I don't I've seen people talk
about Comics you know like like regular
people and they'll be like yeah I love
this guy he just does the same [__] all
the time like same [__] same and one
time I saw a a waitress watching a comic
reciting I've seen it the kiss she just
reciting it not she wasn't yelling out
she was going she was mouthing it K
that's how often this person this never
changes their act and I go and I was
watching it from I go oh I don't ever
want that to happen to me that just gave
me a challenge totally you know so I go
and I go you know what I'm just going to
challenge myself and plus I was always
working out new [__] all the time I
never ever stop working out new [__] I
would just go I'm gonna try this I would
take a lot of chances I could tell take
a lot I was around remember I was around
Gerald all those guys so we were chance
takers we were just okay I'm gonna try
that I'm gonna try that and Gerald
always said he's like man how the [__]
do you always doing new [__] I go I just
do it I don't give I don't give a you
got you can't give a [__] yeah that's
pretty cool coming from him though too
yeah oh yeah he would be like I [__]
hate you you [__] did a brand new
[__] J I go yeah and Colin Quinn
taught me to milk a joke like when I he
first saw me do my Nigerian dad joke I
started at the Boston Comedy Club Boston
used to have 10 people in the [__]
room but it was a good workout room in
the middle of the in the week so when I
was working on Co I was working for
Cosby I think I I work for Cosby you do
warmup for Cosby warmup I do eight hour
warm-ups I'd be [__] dead but I would
take the train and go and Gina Savage
who works there now Gina was running the
Boston comedy club and Gina would be
like you want to do a set at at at 2 I
would say yeah I'm coming from this from
Queens I'm going to do my set and so I
would come and I would just you know
work out new [__] you know what I mean
that's what I did I there less pressure
at that time yeah you just [__] around
and then you were getting new [__] you
go oh that was good and Colin saw me do
my dad's joke the first time I ever did
my I said let me talk about being
Nigerian man what the [__] I was born in
Nebraska I'm Nigerian grew up in Chicago
[__] you know a lot there so I started
to let me talk about me so my first joke
was was yeah I said what do I going to
do about my dad without putting him down
I said uh yeah when I I remember when
people used to call my parents house you
know how you say it when you're a suck
comedy yeah um lot ofs it's like yeah
anyway anyway you guys are good you're
good you guys ever have a dad you ever
have dad who has a dad yo that's crazy
crazy [__] out
there give it up for the ladies huh yeah
anyway what was I talking about dads
right right so he's like my dad was my
dad I'm Nigerian you know blah blah blah
I said if you don't believe me I used to
say call my parents house my father pick
up the phone you think you talk to The
Lion King right so I'd be like can I
hello can I speak to Godfrey Godfrey is
not
here see and that's the laughter I got
and I said and and then he was like and
then they would start to crank call him
because they don't believe him hello a
click and I got big that was the only
that was all the joke had I didn't have
anything else yeah and but it got big
last I said okay I can build around
andin saw it and he goes like this he
goes like this I didn't know you were
nigeran how you [__] work on that he
go this he goes no this is what you got
to do you got to work on it you got to
you got to you got to got you got to
have [__] levels to that you milk
that [__] don't stop stay in that
[__] joke he T he told me that [__]
wow he told me to stop hosting at the
seller too really I hosted at the seller
for 5 years when I passed SD wanted me
to host cuz I had all this energy I've
seen you host and you're [__] great
no I was why you need to get out of that
I could host my ass so people be like yo
bring the host I was that dude I know be
Greg roel it would be Greg rogel Barry
they were always the first two cuz they
were low energy Greg roel there it was
all them and I would host from 9:00 to
3: in the morning Jesus it was no it
were no little shows it was just one
show and they pay you for one show yeah
and you had to pay the comics they give
you the money and the receipts hilarious
oh my you got de Todd Barry's going up
after you I'm I'm going to bring the
energy down real quick hey folks how you
doing but can I just say all these I
mean now I sound like old man Norma but
these young Comics that get one viral
thing on Tik Tok you're like a blue
collar guy clocking in you work at The
Cosby Show You Train down then you work
at a 2 a.m. with 10 people in the crowd
I mean it was For the Love of the Game
back then you like maybe I'll get on the
tonight's show maybe who knows and and a
lot of these cats they go viral they're
selling out [__] and D you're selling
out I'm it's going good listen you're
selling tickets God thank God I got well
I was selling tickets before because I
would do like MTV yeah and seven up
commercials whatever but I feel like
each Year's got to be better for you
right yeah because of that social I'm
glad I got on that [__] six
years ago seven even though they
suspended
my my account is suspended right now why
is that just [__] talking [__] to
somebody was talking [__] back to me I
go oh shut your fat hit and they go oh
Community guidelines God it's getting so
dangerous man it's like just I I wasn't
saying anything political I didn't talk
about Palestine Israel I didn't do any
of that I just said yeah shut the [__]
up like that
shitz it's so it's so dangerous because
it's like I mean look there's many forms
of censorship right but this is we talk
about like censors on TV this is censors
on social media oh yeah they're they're
they're silencing you they're making it
so you can't say what you want to say
and there's so much crazy [__] on there
that they don't censor and this is the
[__] they choose they choose that but
then there's skin heads and all kinds of
[__] but it's an algorithm that doesn't
understand sarcasm either so it's
like get an Al algorithmic sarcastic
[__] program you say the word Nazi
even if you're like [__] on Nazis or
you're being sarcastic about Nazis he
said the word Nazi yeah so the algorithm
no [__] whatever yeah so that's what
happening happened to Skanks the Legion
of skanks you know they got I saw that
on YouTube well they keep the gopost
keeps moving in that's the problem like
those guys have always been like going
for it which I would go yeah they would
go all like [__] you know what racial
[__] and I like yeah leou is squeezing
everything out of that Puerto Rican bar
rack he's like I can say the N word I
got you know a little brown on me
there's got to be a you build up a
profile but there's something [__] up
about being able to build a profile on
this like you put so much into building
up your YouTube and now YouTube's like
oh you can't do that anymore it's like
okay we we could like a year ago exactly
a warning yeah they should have a
warning they send us like a digital
pamphlet yeah I like pamphlets I no one
uses that word anymore give me a
pamphlet like hey this don't do this
don't do this don't do that I've been
doing lives now on my what's it called
on my podcast I'm doing the um YouTube
uh account I'm lo I didn't know that it
was that dope I I'm getting super chat
you make money oh right right and my
buddy you know Chad zumach oh geez
[__] nuts Chad zumach who always
fights with Kevin Brennan and [__] but
Chad I've known for a long time and Chad
goes you know you should be going on
your lives with your um your your your
your podcast so I went on there I have
45,000 subscribers damn didn't think to
go live on there aard you know yeah and
I've been doing it on Instagram
Instagram's been my thing cuz I've done
sketches on there and then they go you
should be on YouTube I go YouTube looks
I said YouTube looks too hard yeah but
it's not it is overwhelming though you
it's overwhelming but I forgot I built
up all these subscribers yeah 4 I may I
got 15,000 new ones this this week like
in a week and a half I got 15,000 new
subscrib subscribers from going live
from going live whoa so and they're Sing
Money
yeah [__] you guys don't do that I
should be doing that we did it for I did
it for my special that was about it when
I put out a YouTube special went live
you like going is live your thing you
guys don't seem like the guys that I'll
do it like I'll do like a little Q&A
sometimes but like I'm in I'm in a hotel
room I'm boarded I'm like I'll try to be
funny and uh and thing but uh you know
but it's uh no talk basketball you know
or something yeah that's not bad we go
on live together sometimes I'm down for
that you do that dude that's badass yeah
basketball the whole you know um yeah so
that's um what's been happening with me
thank God I did social media man doing
doing um uh my like characters and that
has gone viral a lot of times what so I
know some of the great impressions you
do but some what are some Impressions
that you don't like you're great at but
you don't do a lot some obscure ones I
do Jason Statum pretty good because I
did it on Jim Norton's show he brought
Jason Statum to um and I yeah oh yeah
I'm a transporter is what I do
I knew it gfy I heard you were talking
like me yeah wow on I did yeah and Jim
Norton called me and says godre I'm
bringing Jason Statum on you have to you
got you have to come on you have to come
on I said okay I came on there Jason
Statum I'm talking with Jason St I'm
like what the [__] man and then Opie it
was Opie and Jim at the time and Opie
goes yeah you do a Jason I didn't know
when he was going to say it I go [__]
Jason oh that's when he was a SC High di
he was diving yeah he's diving when he
what what a hunk yeah he was he's a bad
mother he's just a badass he's just been
a badass forever and he's still going
he's in that new movie Bumblebee man or
whatever beekeeper beekeeper that's it
bumblebee man I think that's the
Simpsons
guy the the Mexican guy yeah how about
are you are you pumped the Trump is back
because you get to bring back Trump I'm
so H listen man let's keep it real we're
happy he's back you know my you know
Shane Gillis all of us that do Trump
it's gonna be it's gonna be Cat
Williams I I did a I did a trump Cat
Williams thing and it was cool have a
[__] up wig but I have you know all
you do is have a red tie and a blue
jacket people know you could just put a
you could put a nest on your head as
long as it's blonde Cat Williams very
good video smart to combine them Cat
Williams Puerto
Ric oh is this from Rich Eisen Cat
Williams is smart because he's he's he
[__] on Rogan and Rogan's like come on I
lik about Rogan Rogan I mean but like
cat said oh there you go wow you're not
[__] around with that wig I'm going
to be your president you know what it is
2024 your president but enough about me
enough about me did you
see the amazing interview by Cat
Williams I'll repeat it again Cat
Williams William very very very funny
comedian I never really heard about Cat
Williams never really heard about him
until this week when I saw his interview
wow it's broken the internet I know what
it's the only time you get a comedian in
a suit is when they're doing an
impression of someone else and then I
even said uh you know Club Shay is um
shad and sharp Show Club sh he go
welcome Club
Shay Club CH that's Club sh and I and I
said club
shaa and then I said Club sha
shank
shank nice yeah I love that it it sant's
graling to Trump is so funny I mean
after after vona santis when he he
backed out so just watching him like try
to go Trump and then lose to Trump and
like Trump in front of this like you
know him just having to be like know
santis like when I would hear about how
Des santis was like cancelling black
history [__] just he was just this
hardcore Governor then when I heard him
talk I go are you you [__] he goes I
just want to tell you listen um I hope
to run for president you know get your
[__] [__] ass boy listen listen to
him talk this [__] ass voice by the way
Hampshire oh wow it's not the governor
of
Florida New Hampshire listen guys listen
man but then you watch Trump he's like
working on nicknames the way we work on
material where he's like where he's like
fat Ronda Sanders and no one laughs and
then the next week he's like meet B Ron
and it kills he's like it's in the act
in the comic he worked it out com please
show you shower watch this we left it
all out on the field now following our
second place finish in Iowa we've prayed
and deliberated on the way forward I've
never really listened to him [__]
made he's [__] made get the [__] out
Florida like Florida be like godamn Flor
Gator me D and he's like this my [__]
State I want to tell
you [__] Miran can run for
[__]
yes Miran Kagan shout out to Miran KAG
yo that's [__] yo I'm just like
whatever the [__] out of here I like the
picture Trump calling Gina Savage I
gotta come down there I got a couple
nicknames to work out Gina Savage got
some words oh just trying to work some
things out that would be hilarious if we
got bumped by Trump SP God Trump just
comes on he's like he's like sleepy Joe
it's in the ACT Trump would sell the
[__] out people would like yo Trump does
yeah he's got a rally he could do he
could sell the [__] out he sells
merch about what about show Trump when
he goes when the lady what's her Megan
Good that little hot little the the mean
one the hot one from Fox when she
Kelly oh and she goes Trump goes just
Rosie O'Donald and the place laughs like
a comedy club oh pull it up and he and
he's waiting goes just Rosie oon and the
place I mean they're laughing like you
know like a Death Jam right the black
people laugh yeah watch watch this [__]
this sh is so is this it um this is a
man who is called women pigs no no no
not that one is it Megan someone who has
said there's only one is an
inconvenience to employers who has said
women don't
deserve no you got to get Megan Kelly it
has to be the one where he goes you say
you you this is when he was like a more
chill cuz in the Biden debates he's like
cutting him off he's like shut up shut
up but here he's like no not true I
cannot wait for him to to I'm sorry it's
just going to be great it's F okay here
we go oh she's good looking oh dogs
slobs
and disgusting animals he perks up only
Ros
o watch the place watch this watch the
place Fu Dam Isam holy [__] dying wow he
stole that from Mark
Curry [__] ass watch his face when he
comes with the line in his
head yes he's got the light slobs and
dis there it is there it
is don't do that again that's [__]
amazing he even grabs the yeah he sets
it up we listen to that perk slobs
and yo this pop up he's a [__] pest
dispenser what the
[__] almost like a Rodney like here it
comes I tell you yo that was let's do
dueling Rodney real
quick he does a better Rodney no I don't
I'll tell you you're all right you're a
great crowd great crowd wow great Crow I
tell you Johnny I got a lot of work
Johnny each just pick your favorite my
mother never brushed me hold let me do
it again thank you I got I got I got a
Thro my mother never brasted me she told
me she liked me as a friend that's
[__] great great he's like uh I like
my wife always told me why don't you
take me somewhere different I took it to
the
kitchen I go on a Rodney Dangerfield
like I go on a um Rabbit Hole like every
couple weeks and he was on Johnny Carson
over 300 something times is that right
wow 300 I think it was yeah Carson
insane there's there's some Rodney
Dangerfield interviews where Carson
literally forgets about the other guest
and has Rodney on so long that Rodney
goes uh so how you doing Johnny and
Johnny just goes he just run ca he he
loved him so much he made him a
superstar and Johnny let you sit down I
think it's over 3 I how many the one
where Detroit that's a great place I'll
pick up some plugs and points while I'm
there too I think you know what I
mean
I mean the center stage the center stage
in Detroit Friday night they they didn't
have that down there they didn't have
that down there well what are they going
to do the center stage in C State I
dangerfields Saturday night i' be in
dangerfields the whole month of June you
got to keep busy all you know I relax
too you know oh yeah you not a relac I
went to a wild party did you tell us
about it well I played a new version of
Russian Roulette yeah we passed around
six girls and one of them had
VB by the way dressed exactly like
Trump interesting interesting he uh I
was watching back to school the other
day it's just it's the best movie but
the line it's like even the throwaway
lines when he's talking about his Bert
Young's talking about Rodney's shitty
x-wife he goes hey don't knock Vanessa
she gives great
headache that's like a throwaway that's
great I love that [__] yeah man that's
when and I have a oh this a good story
you remember
Fabio okay now Fabo Italian like model
super yeah Fabio works out at my gym in
um La what Equinox on Sunset okay right
off Sunset so Fabio and I love Fabio cuz
Fabio does not play games he's all about
[__] he don't play games he's like
Italian old school and he goes and and
me and Chad we we have pictures me him
Chad and he goes uh and he and he's
always talking like this you see that
hot oh [__] beautiful like he's he's
like a old school creep not creep but he
creep on girls but he was a supermodel
so he used to live in New York and he
told me the story he goes you guys do
comedy right yeah he goes you know I
have a great story of Rodney Dangerfield
so we used to live in the Palladium it
was a really expensive apartment place
when he was a supermodel and he goes I
remember we lived down the hall from
Rodney Dangerfield and Rodney one time
you know whenever we would go out you
know we would like play music we play
music cuz you know my all the models
guys are on my house he goes I remember
Rodney Dangerfield he just he would
always have a robe on and be naked under
yeah and he would come in all [__]
you know yeah and one day he broke in
and said hey why how come you never
invite me to your parties you always
have parties you never invite me he goes
Rodney we don't have we just playing
music no you're [__] lying you got to
start inviting me to your parties what
the [__] you know and and and they would
he would do that break in butt naked
with and sometime and then sometimes he
they would have to pick Rodney
Dangerfield up
uh in the middle of the hallway because
he'd be [__] up knocked out so they
had to carry him he goes Rodney was a
wild [__] like yeah yeah he like
get [__] up until he got sober with
this new girl right look at that Sandler
Fabio and Rodney in the room see what
I'm saying yeah yeah yeah that's that's
he gave it yeah gave us that account he
goes yeah this [__] was wild holy moly
tell I drink too much I got a urine
sample they found an olive in it yo that
shit's so good he's classic you heard
the Leno story Rodney's on his deathbed
he's in a coma he's in the hospital and
his wife is there and she's like Jay
just talk to him you know try to make
him feel better I don't know if he can
hear you but he's in a coma so do do
whatever you can and Jay's like all
right and he puts his finger in Rodney's
hand it's like that he's out and he goes
uh if he squeezes your finger that means
he feels you and he squeezes his finger
and Jay goes Rodney I love you that's
not my finger he said Rodney like
twitched so he got to laugh at him right
at the end [__] dope
you I don't want you to be late for your
thing give a thing I'm I'm pushing a
little bit it's no I have to do
something at like there's a car coming
from me I had do one of these you know
these interviews you just it's ABC but
you say what do you feel about people
lengthening their legs you heard about
those new haven't you heard about those
new uh operations they perform now you
can get taller now oh Des
santis you so they break your legs and
they put a thing in in there so you can
be taller yeah there's the new new
operations that are happening so you
have to it's a long recovery too yeah
you got to learn to walk again and I
just think it's that [__] looks
painful is my ticket to the NBA dude I'm
doing it yeah right who's the
spokesperson Tanya Harding comes there
with
[__] I don't even Cat
Williams you want to get
taller but yeah I don't yeah it's the
new thing so did he was like 59 and now
he's like 6'2 but he had to re you know
they have P show pictur of him walking
that's does not seem worth it I mean
insecurity is lucrative well you guys
are tall already so you don't know what
this is like would you would it be worth
a few more I'm 51 if I was short but if
you're already getting [__] who gives a
[__] all right you got a point I mean
but you're married I'm sorry but yeah
but you're getting professional p i yeah
I had a good run but yeah yeah but you
know if you're still getting girl who
gives a [__] that's if you're not
getting any women maybe so but every
actor is like five six man Peter dink is
just getting the giving girls the
Dinklage you know what I mean he must be
right you know he came to the seller
really to see Chappelle was there and he
was he was [__] up you know whenever
Spell's in town the most random actors
show up right you go how the [__] does
he know all these [__] well it
started with John Mayor you're like what
are they doing together may it it was
mayor was hanging with sherro first oh
interesting and but ese would wanted me
and John Mayor to hang out but I was
never around I was always out gone unro
but he started hanging with shro tight
then James Smith remember James Smith
love Jam I just saw him in Australia
James Smith was I'm not gonna lie James
Smith is a cloud chaser I said it James
great great comedian but he's a cloud
chaser he's very funny though cuz J and
I love James James I said dude you're so
[__] hilarious your joke writing is
dope and but he was John mayor's dude
then cuz I this is I remember when it
got too bad because Shad didn't want
anybody hanging out with John Mayer he
didn't want anybody talking to John
Mayor for too long I'm not even
bullshitting you then like his
girlfriend it was weird then J then
James Smith one day me and John are
talking and his brother I think his
brother's name's Carl John has a brother
who's taller than him because you know
John is like
6263 brother his brother Carl is a is a
business guy taller than him so we're
all hanging and he's with his Dad he
brought his dad too to the seller and
we're all talking and then James comes
over and goes are you all right buddy
you good buddy I was like James get the
[__] out of here we're in the same
restaurant right yeah it got really
weird oh no yeah it got really weird so
yeah and so you know but um John tried
to do comedy too yeah and I remember
sitting with David tell David you know
how David T Waits on the stairs he was
waiting on the stairs way to go on at
the Sellar John mayor's on stage oh boy
this is not a recipe for something good
John's on stage and John listen great
guitarist the whole nine so John's doing
some weird [__] on stage not working
right Dave goes
up you know how Dave could like he does
this thing where he's talking about you
but it's so clever yeah just that jab
like that Ali [__] he goes he's like
John mayor he's like John Mayor doing
comedy he goes you know what you can see
me around the corner playing
[Laughter]
guitar is it
killing show the Shannon sharp laugh
brother and he was crushing with this
right oh it was woo it was I was there I
was like oh that was beautiful I love
when it
tells tells K so hard that he starts
banging the
microphone d
do you remember anything else he said
from that set the the John Mayor lines
[__] no he just said that because he was
waiting and he's like what what are you
doing like and I and he just did it and
mayor laugh but he knew it was a jab I
it I was right there I was like good you
got to laugh but he like get off yeah
it's not for everybody just play your
guitar yeah I don't you could be a fan
of Comedy but you don't see us take
guitar lessons no I would like to but
you know I'm not going to I'm not going
to go and join a band yeah if I if I
want to learn instrument but it's for
myself I'm not going to go hey you
didn't see me on Monday at the seller I
know you hear that gnome got up with the
band
already no's a fantastic uh incred his
father was a a a mandolin playero oh
really there's a there's footage of his
dad playing in the 60s playing yeah man
[__] what a cool fan what a cool
lineage you know L yeah man do you still
I don't see with the seller quite as
much you still coming down a lot you
mean the original seller well either I
don't know no I'm always we just our
timing is our busy I'm on the road you
know I've been going there earlier
because I I'll show you why Sal you can
play you can play this is I see you
you're oh you don't do late night [__]
you guys I saw you know last week I'm
there always late I like The Late Late
For Me works for me cuz it's just makes
it better for you yeah I think that's
where aiz anari started following me I
know aiz strange dude but he's always
been my friend yeah but he goes he goes
he goes man he's like I've been going
late because you're always late I think
it it make I want to do what you're
doing it challenges it challenges you
and that's I've always been the late
dude just I just me Dave Dave we just
like late and I stay late know and then
it's too after everybody's done their
[__] you don't have to worry about
anybody bitching about you being on
there too long that's why I would go if
I go late I'm going to do extra time cuz
I'm the last guy the difference everyone
I did everyone did the unicycle [__]
they did this is why I'm calling early
what my outside my
window oh damn every day for five months
nine months five months 16
18 but that's how they get paid they
take their time they hit two they go
like this dink dink break time oh dude
this this is better than it used to be
they used to be on my window just
banging on the window what they fix what
are they doing I don't [__] under
Section 11 horeshit where they they have
to make sure loose bricks don't fall out
so they're going through every brick in
the building they're building houses for
the migrants yeah that's they they they
extend I my friend works construction he
goes yeah we take our time get that
money you know you got oh yeah Union
yeah un keep those [__] cones around
there and start hammering away and you
don't know what the [__] we're banging
on ear I used to be a late night guy
there too but I'm like I can't I get
woken up at [__] 8:15 from that [__]
I got what time do you get to do the
seller seller I've been calling in I'm
like just I only do early o00 8:00 yeah
like like I'll do like 9 or 10 but after
after not after 10 anymore because just
because the [__] I used to I used to
love the late shows because it would be
a TA I would just watch but early shows
are fun too it's like Quinn and and
nordon and [__] and the Crowds Are So
behaved there they're almost too really
behaved nordan's new [__] man is so
funny he's great oh my God it's all
about his his trans wife it's [__]
incredible I got to see that [__] it's
so funny and like you never heard
perspective yeah he was always a he
always talked about that Twisted [__]
though yep he was always before
everybody before was cool yes and I
remember he would go I always because I
don't know I learned from the seller on
how to [__] on the crowd and dig a hole
and come back out of it I I I was never
like hey guys I was like yo what you
[__] horrible crowd what's up yeah yeah
you know and Dave was like that and Jim
Jim was the best cuz he'd go up people
like give up for Jim Norton he'd be like
he goes what did I suck on the way
up I hate you people he when I
auditioned I had to follow Norton it was
a height of O Anda so he was like a star
and he was riffing he was killing and a
hot lady walked to the bathroom and he
goes holy [__] are you single she goes
yeah and he goes what's your name she
goes I'm Sheila he goes I'm going to
[__] Sheila in the bathroom kills he
gets off and I'm freaking out cuz I'm on
next I'm auditioning I'm a young nobody
and I go up and I just go well that's a
little awkward I was I was dating chil a
minute ago and he killed thank God but
it was a risk big risk nice job was
there she was like oh I like that I
thought you were like the way you
bounced off oh I remember esie ese got
good comedic timing too there's a guy we
I remember some dude I don't think he
was a regular at the Sellar so he was
eating his balls he was like a hack
comic from some [__] City and he came
on there tried to get that juice and
that that New York [__] just ate his
ass up so he comes up just I remember
this [__] he goes up Keith goes on next
Keith goes on murdering and so the guy
comes he goes yeah the crowd just didn't
get me and then he goes well Keith is
killing what EXC oh my God that's
heartbreaking [__] his on Kei I don't
understand she's quick what what did
what did he say to that he goes he goes
no K is killing it was you oh yeah was
oh yeah it was sure ke this ke this
killing we were there for brunch last
weekend and John lter was like you know
it says here is crazy that what's the
average people amount of people most
people have sex with in their life and
the average was five and I was like five
that's insane and ESD goes it is more
than
five she's quick like that he's [__]
yeah man damn this is cool I do got to
leave though plug some dates coming up
when is this showing when is it coming
up good
question that is a damn February be like
January I'll be at the yeah right
February 4th okay not bad hey black
history black history month y'all plan
this on purpose the white man always an
agenda hey gy come on the set I go is it
February yeah shortest
month I think we got 29 days this year
though oh no yeah [__] they're always
late yeah
yo um check it out okay February okay
the 9th and 10th I'm at zany in in in um
uh
Tennessee Zan it's a great Club Zan's
the ninth and 10th all right show the
[__] up it'll be good I always have a
good time there shout out to Lucy she's
fantastic she's great um the 15th to the
18th San Antonio LOL San Antonio the
15th to the 18th and then I got um oh
West nyak westak nice 22 such a great
Club 22nd to the 25th West nyak Levity
Live Levity Live and then go to godfre
live.com all my dates up there nice
Godfree live.com check out where I'm
going to be you know I got dates all the
way up to December I think and also go
to every show cuz he does a different
[__] hour half the time go and I want
to be like these I got to give you all
credit I love what you guys are doing I
love you doing theaters you earned it
you [__] earned it you guys are some
of the greatest comedians around that's
your writings and I watch all your I
watch all you guys' [__] I love your
videos I love your jokes you guys have
[__] earned it cuz I've watched you
and I've seen you work so and you guys
continue to work so congrats on you guys
man which is badass that's why I say I'm
coming back on your [__]
podcast and shout out to Adam Cora who
always puts me on his podcast oh you
kill it on there he's a he's a big fan
he goes godre I need you on my podcast
again come on and he he's so odd but he
loves me because he produces with my my
first agent one of my first agents Mike
um Mike August you know he does a lot of
uh car oh yeah um documentaries and so I
was watching all his race car
documentaries I'm a big doc fan and I go
Mike August I go Producer Mike go [__] I
know Mike August it sounds like my agent
and he goes yeah I was like that's my
agent agent so yeah he's a his producing
partner is my was my first agent so yeah
Corolla man he shows me a lot of love
too so you guys do we love you man and
yeah I'll be in uh I'll be in Dallas
Addison Improv OKC Bricktown Comedy Club
irine improv those are Salt Lake City
and then new special with the Wilbur so
looking forward to that I'm going to
shoot a I'm shooting my December I'm
going to shoot December 14th I want to
shoot a special I love the [__] I
love the sam.com shows yeah W's the best
a pod too podcast my podcast in Godfrey
we trust on gas digital he I've been on
it yeah I got to come back sometime
great gas digital Network
uh Tuesdays and Fridays me and Dante and
it's I'm I'm celebrating my 500th
episode oh uh 500 I'm gonna do it live
at the stand I've never done a live
episode so I'm at the stand uh on
January 30th so but you know that's cool
that'll be great hey Mark Roman
comedy.com coming all over your face
Houston San Antonio Charlotte Boise Salt
Lake Atlanta Raleigh Austin we're
working guys Tucson Phoenix yeah we got
you're working never take your work for
granted guys
go away at any moment we're in a boom
baby say yo what there was one comic
he's not a real comic Instagram comic
and he's he has so many followers that
day he's not really that good at Comic
he packs theaters he goes anybody does
comedy clubs why I go no dude 99% of
comics do comedy Cubs because it's a
[__] comedy club that's what
comedians that was my plan was to get to
make the [__] fit for the for the taping
you know listen even way you go to
theaters and comedy clubs you always
want both you always want both because
these comedy clbs aren't small some of
them are four 500 seats not easy to fill
I don't give a [__] if it's a d room not
easy to bring people to come and see you
and there's waiters walking around
there's chicken wings there's checks
there seaters that people are trying to
get people to come to so it's a big
privilege and don't ever take it for
granted you don't ever take that [__]
for granted I'm telling you 2008 when
they had that big financial and Comics
weren't working they were like I'm never
going to refuse a gig I said I never de
you shouldn't take that for granted bro
there you go me right on get some Bodega
cat and check out
guys Boda cat whiskey.com all right
thank you guys
[Laughter]
CL a know the be close I've had a little
too B and Norman talking [__] about the
[__] and I get down in the same way
Up on the Roof like a cop coming and
naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember her and I get down in the same
way we
might
be
[Music]
true